what else you got tim this is just uh
something i saw
on a fishing instagram thing it just
looked cool it just looked cool
tag a buddy this reminds you of so he's
barefoot water skiing
i don't have a friend and then he does
that i don't have a friend
that's a girl or i think so but yeah so
he's just barefoot
waterskiing then goes onto the land how
cool is that
do you think that's cool
is this an outtake from peanut butter
falcon
oh man
doesn't he look a little like the
wrestling
yo yo references this girl was just
waiting there with the drink like this
yo what what what's this girl's like
this stupid [ __ ] yeah
again stupid what if you don't land this
time babe man what if you want land this
time you babe do i have to do it
yes just hold the [ __ ] corona jenny
dale
just have it have it for me this [ __ ]
hold the drink [ __ ] just a six tape
babe come on
housewives on oh my god chin was crunk
with that video
dope hey are you boys ready get it i
know right
we were like just watching
no i thought it was cool yeah
hey how you did the intro again i hit it
all right guys i got one for you
[Laughter]
now it's time to have a little fun this
was sent in by keith
underscore
i'm about to rock your
i'm about to blow your mind man
here's keith from missouri he sent this
in thanks for the shout out
good luck fishing this weekend we're
gonna send keith two t-shirts
keith make sure you send your address to
your size to the
tf the tf team gmail.com
man like i heard you had a wetsuit but
have you had this suit
malice crying right now
now it's time for a little fun y'all
y'all ready to bring this party up you
all ready turn it up mala you the hype
man but listen to this
you ready to get hyped huh bout to bring
the whole house down
[Applause]
goes well i thought it was fun yeah
i got a little guilt oh my god okay
oh my god this one's for you keith
oh man he came in lower he's trying to
pick this tone up
are you ready yo
yo you're stupid okay all right hashtag
fishing is
yeah he's not my friend
bro what the hell oh my god hook the
fishing
follow follow the fishing please right
now talk about brand new tags being that
you're not my friend
i should tell you oh my god go to the
comments it's gonna be like hey
i'm cute but does anyone care i don't
anymore
oh my god don't tag a buddy this reminds
you of [ __ ]
nobody matter of fact this video upsets
me
why is this the current event oh my god
hook to fishing
oh my god bro we got to detach
do you want to go get another one let's
just leave off on this one no let's give
me one why i want to end on this one all
right
check this out how cool is this
chingos you guys are having fun it's
getting a lot funner
check out these two cats in the cactus
what is this [ __ ] bobcats and then hey
guys
it's
[Applause]
hey guys and now we're going to turn to
nature hey guys
that one was fun you're about to have a
whole lot more fun
hey tim this isn't america's funniest
videos
it's crazy though this ain't crazy
look it's like oh my god yeah
that's why they're in the cactus weather
are you ready for some desert fun
wait did somebody say cats no
no well that's not fun oh my god
oh man yo today's curtain event is
brought to you by
when did we go straight yeah what
happened to this
when did we get on abc 7.
oh my god bruh what are they doing okay
let's talk about the pictures we're
talking about the hose on flavor of love
and chin's like yeah
i don't like this hey guys yo he was
like
oh my god you know what's so funny that
hashtag pisses me off
you know some money [ __ ] really prepped
before the show like oh man
yep no the guys are gonna love y'all
they go
i'm about to kill them i'm about to kill
it because i saw it i was like okay yeah
because we walked in chappelle before
everyone just let me hide this because i
don't wanna i'm surprised
this is going to blow your mind i did
i did
he was like we got these black guys
again watch this [ __ ]
let's see how black guys react the cats
and the crackers
i hate cats chin you know this oh my god
he had an option not to detonate it he
was like y'all want to eat on this i
want to hit on this because i got
yeah and then and then there's bad jokes
underneath that's a bob cactus
oh my god i think we should have ended
him
he i wish we did yeah
i gave you all the opportunity oh man
i wouldn't even post that if i was in
arizona and walked by a tree
and those two guys like those stupid
[ __ ] cats man we'd keep going
wouldn't we
hey you know look he tried to give us a
disclaimer he's not cast as bobcats
they're [ __ ] bobcats guys figure it
out i was back home in arizona that's
why
oh my god yeah when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song